so why the personal in this course well
at every occasion in when the students
present the discussions because you have
to frame the discussion or when they
write the essays I do ask them to
include some personal information in
what they write in fact one essay was
strictly about that about the linguistic
biographies because I feel that often
students can be overly ambitious of
course there's this Venice nests that we
appreciate but often they want to go
after global changes like changing the
environment or changing the outcome of
elections but those are the kind of
changes that you often cannot make
especially not in a one semester course
but if they're able to understand the
way those global patterns affect their
own personal lives and their own small
social groupings and if they can
actually try to integrate what they
learn in the course two actions in this
localized spheres then there's a better
chance that they actually make those
changes so I like to tell them that the
change that they can make in themselves
Vasavi those issues are also affecting
the wider world because if each person
can affect themselves in their small
groups and in turn if everyone in that
small group can also affect changes in
the own small groups then the effect is
exponential you see so and I think
reading of the course they do appreciate
being able to share the personal
experiences through essays through the
presentations and also they can see the
effect that this has on the own
classmates because some of the
classmates come from very different
backgrounds and so they get to
understand how someone say from
Guatemala who came to the US with
parents that immigrated without papers
and how that life experience can be
inspiring because if you can make it to
MIT with that kind of background and
then you can actually share it with
others while you're actually succeeding
an emetic student that can be
life-changing for some of us